out of respect to our next guest chris
brockman when you came up with the poll
question of which quarterback
is most likely to get the week
which quarterback currently back up is
most likely going to get a start first
you chose jordan love as well and i said
i said out of respect
we cannot do that respect aaron rodgers
as well as our next guest
um who is a die hard packers fan and
also the host of a new podcast releasing
episodes every single tuesday in oral
history
of the office podcast where all podcasts
are available now also exclusively on
on spotify uh brian baumgartner here on
the rich eisen show how are you sir
i'm doing great what is this what is
this shenanigans that he's throwing out
before i'm even on
i don't even understand well brian um
look
you're dealing with a guy who the number
12 he's been rooting for for the last 20
years was tom brady so he likes throwing
shade in the directions of other people
who aren't nearly as fortunate to be
waterskiing behind six championship
yachts like he has
so uh i think he just wanted to throw
jordan love out there
um uh as getting a start uh
before any other backup will this year
and i i found that appalling
so i i blocked it i used my preemptory
as host brian
there you go excellent very very well
done good luck at the with the
buccaneers this year by the way
great good luck there well the old
battle of the bays should be interesting
when that happens later on this year
brian i mean uh what do you think of
your packers coming into uh
2020 oh
you know what they made the nfc
championship game last year that's true
i mean that's that's it i their schedule
is tough
but uh i think they're going to be
stiffer up front
that's what she said um and i think
i i have hope i i of course it's like
oh this is this is great new this is
great insight for me to
start off the show i wish they'd gotten
him a little more help
like everyone has been uh discussing yes
uh
with guys uh catching the ball but um
you know i i i remain positive and
steadfast in my resolve
you know what i i don't blame you for
doing that because if
uh things kind of bounced a a little bit
your way
last year the packers could have been
the one seed and but yeah that that's
that selection of jordan love you know
three years from now you might be or
four years from now you might be you
know high-fiving you're
the packer fan of your left to your
right but right now that that one was a
total head scratcher to me brian as it
was to aaron rodgers
uh yes a little confusing to say the
least
a little confusing so do you uh have you
ever played golf with aaron
uh many times okay many
many times okay yeah you know we're
we're we're
we're buddies yeah
it sounds like this sounds like fight
club are you not supposed to talk about
your friendship with aaron because i
don't want to get
no uh no we play a lot of golf uh
together in fact uh we were uh we were
paired up twice this year at the old
american century championship right in
lake tahoe
um and that was that was a lot of fun he
i
he usually plays better when he plays
with me unfortunately
uh i'm happy i'm happy for him about
that
in a in a in a way and also disappointed
in a way
um but uh yeah we had we had a we had a
really great time
he was at the birth of my child for the
love of
all that's pete so we're yeah we've been
friends for a long time
well uh tj jefferson rich eisen show
social media grand maester has provided
us a photograph
that appears to be um aaron rodgers
uh next to ashton kutcher and in between
aaron rodgers and you as one michael
jeffrey jordan
that looks like that photograph to me
where was i where was this taken
that was taken at uh at
uh jordan's um mj's uh
charity event that he used to have uh in
the bahamas
although i think that's when he had
moved it to las vegas i have that photo
as well that does look like a little
shadow creek
action back there a little shadow creek
oh yeah
because mr coocher was there yes that
was shadow that's right
let's see what with by the way a belt
buckle that might be as large as the
actual
uh lake that man-made lake that was
behind mike april the first
2012. there you go there you go all
right very good let's
let's be clear mr coocher was not
playing golf i'm not
exactly sure what he was doing but he
was there for a while
he was caddying it does look was he
really cutting for michael jordan in
jeans
he did come out and caddy for a few
holes yes i remember dwight
dwight freeman was our forest and that
that foursome that we have
yeah so where was freynia did franny
take the picture no i took the picture
okay i'm not sure where franny was at
that point but yeah that was the
foursome oh you took the picture yeah he
did
oh yeah well
brian doesn't know me so he doesn't know
who he's speaking
there you go but that was there well but
ashton was dressed like burt reynolds
from like hooper is what it looks like
to me right there so
very good nice day right there confusing
brian bob gartner here on the rich eisen
show where did you come up with the
uh the idea for this pod man it's so
popular obviously the office is as
popular as
ever um an oral history of the office
walk me through how you
um came up with this one sir well
really it is because of what you just
said that the office is more popular
than ever uh
you know for we were the number one
scripted show on nbc
for a lot of the time that the show was
on um
but we haven't filmed anything in seven
years
and based on any metric now
it is the most watched show in
television which is
just insane um and i'm including like
shows that are being made right now
so part of it was the idea of trying to
figure out why
like why it has caught such fire and
becomes sort of the cultural phenomenon
that
that it is today and and really why do
young
people like it like why are like you
know
14 year olds and 13 12 year old like why
are they watching it because we never
thought we were making a show for kids
right we thought we were making a show
that people who were
working in offices might relate to um
and so it was really for me the podcast
is a is a journey and an
active exploration trying to figure out
why in the world as the show
um not just survive this long but is
actually now thriving
more than ever after all of this time
well in terms of kids
that kind of nix is the reason why i
would proffer to say
it's so popular is well obviously other
than the writing and the acting and
and and obviously the mock documentary
um that that that it uh it sends up
quite a bit with the way that it's shot
um
we've all had bosses that are just not
not competent
and goes to work thinking that it's
entertainment
that that all a good boss has to be is
just entertaining
and that we've all had that and we've
all had
kooky uh um co-workers and we've all had
people
who are know-it-alls at work and we've
also you know
seen office romances i mean it it just
speaks to so many different levels
yeah so rich when we look at it our
friend ben silverman who executive
produced the show yes
when when when he gets asked why is it
popular he's like
well because it's funny right
i think he's right but i think what i
have found
through doing talking to so many people
and doing this podcast
is exactly what you are talking about is
what we thought like when we were on set
and i don't remember the number right
but it was like well there are 200
million americans who work in offices
across the country so
if we can just find a small percentage
of those people that can relate
well then we're great right like we're
this is a home run
so i think what i we never realized even
we never realized when we were making it
what the parallel between being stuck
in an office with people you don't
choose to be with
right with an unreasonable boss the
parallel between
that to being stuck in a classroom
with an unreasonable teacher that maybe
makes you do things you don't want to do
and you have to sit next to people who
you don't choose to sit next to
and there's the cool kids with the
romance and
and it relates i think to them in a way
that we never imagined when we were
making it
brian baumgartner here on the rich eisen
show who are you channeling as as kevin
brian um
i don't know no seriously you didn't
have like a co-worker that uh
any you know was there anybody that you
based
your portrayal on at all or no no
no and i think i think one of the things
that made the show
so unique and different was that the
people who were the actors who were
involved
all came from different places right so
like
you had bj novak and craig robinson who
were like stand-up guys and
steve carell and angela kenzie who were
like improv people
for me myself and rayne wilson
we were like we came straight from
theater so for me it was really about
constructing and building a character
and
i where it came from i don't know just
like the dark recesses of my brain
again the dark recesses of your brain i
love that
i'll accept that as an answer i just was
wondering if there was anybody
out there and you know ed helms for a
very very long time correct
brian went to high school together it's
amazing that is amazing
i've aged like a fine wine that maybe
has too much
tannin uh ed we ed
and i don't look the same but yes i am
i'm i was
well i don't know how many years but i i
was one class ahead of them and we were
we were close friends our parents are
friends and yeah we've known each other
a lot that is the smallest of worlds i
think we have um
something that just got instagram down
maybe even by you is kevin's chili
recipe
um i think we have that right here um
on our program so um yeah there it is
kevin's famous chili whatever you do
don't drop it
i like it there you go oh peacock
instagram this out on their stories and
you know we're on peacock so we're
and this is where uh the office is
headed uh eventually
so um did you have anything to do with
this at all yourself
or this was just something that was
placed in front of you ryan
the the chili rest of the yeah yes sir
no that was just you know there's been a
lot of discussion about it it was
it was so different i mean it was really
unlike anything else that we did on the
show
um and you know this sort of monologue
that i had with the chili and there was
i guess a big discussion in the writers
room like no we can't do this this is
too much this is too much of a departure
and i i knew it was
i loved it to start with did i think
that it was going to appear
as a meme every day for the rest of my
life on social media
no i definitely did not did not envision
that scenario um but i
uh i yeah i'm
tremendously proud that it was one take
that is
that is i guess in a way my claim to
think it will probably be on my
tombstone
gartner that might mean something else
it might not but i think
that's really what um yeah what
what what i will be remembering i mean i
think i i think i saw it even over the
weekend
the meme did you taste it before you
dropped it or no that was just uh
i did not taste it but i will i will
tell you a quick story that
we angela kinsey and oscar nunez and
myself the three accountants we
periodically would go to a nice dinner
after work i think we shot this on a
friday night and we had planned to go
very nice you can guess i'm not going to
give them a plug but
very nice steakhouse in beverly hills
that we had a reservation at
this particular evening and of course
they got off early because i
i was the only one who shot that and i
i did the scene and they had come to me
before and they said we have three
giant pieces of carpet so you can do
this three times but
that's it man you gotta get it we did it
once and as i've joked later like
they could have changed the carpet but
they couldn't change me like i was
so just stained kind of that
yellow or orangey yellow chili
so i get in the shower and i'm like
shower it's the most people i've ever
showered with
too rich i was not a professional
football player there's like
wardrobe people and makeup people and
getting it out of my hair and like all
this stuff
so i leave set happy with myself and i
sit down at this very fancy
uh restaurant in beverly hills and i can
just all i can smell is chili
there's like oscars like i got us a
seafood tower
i'm like i can't all i smell is chili
this is the most
wasted meal of my entire life um
so it's it's stuck around much longer
than the building it lingers
it just like the meme brian you just
can't get it you just can't get it out
you know i mean
it's there it's going to follow you for
a very long time so
um i'll ask the question i'm sure you
get a lot but i'll do it anyway
um getting everyone back together
getting the band back together
getting doing another episode like
literally
having a reunion show is there how
realistic is a chance percentage
that's what we do in the in sports media
is ask a percentage ask
like what percent are you in terms of
readiness or
injured or not coaches were asked what
percentage is it possible to get this
person back in the lineup give me a
percentage
brian um i because of the
way that you asked the question yes sir
i would say
[Music]
it probably exceeds eighty percent
ah wow i don't i could do the math so
there's a
is it better than four out of every five
chances of of asking that you
that this happens yes
but i think i think what i think where
uh
the question a lot of people ask is
about
like rebooting the show like having
that exist again for like another
season or something that number is way
lower
okay but but the idea of getting
everybody back
to do some sort of
reunion event
yeah that's what i would say okay yes
80 but better than 80 because it seems
like you all genuinely like each other
when when
obviously you're talking on your
podcasts um i've
i have gotten to know angela because our
kids go to the same school and she
talks just glowingly about everybody
like everybody seems to genuinely like
everybody
so that might not be an issue and the
popularity is huge
um so i'll ask this then what's hap
what's more likely to happen first
the reunion show or jordan love starts a
game for the green bay packers at
quarterback
um
i can't answer that question but aaron
rodgers is healthy your golf buddy is
healthy
he is he is healthy so you can kind of
give an idea of years
left on contracts you know what i'm
saying what do you think right
are you saying oh wait oh well are you
saying what happens first it
starts a single game or replaces
as qb1 just like you know what because
he could get a cup of coffee if the
packers clinch early enough this is
brian baumgartner
trying to avoid answering the question
with a very salient football point
i'm trying to figure out where i should
go
no and actually like they're they're
saying let's give them a shot let's give
them a look
what happens first
the reunion show or that
you know after this year send them to
new england
[Music]
which is what you know what i mean yeah
okay so
so do i think it's going to be do i
think oh i can answer this
do i think it's going to happen do i
think that the office gang will be
back together before the end of this
football season no
no i don't think so okay i don't i know
all right uh i haven't been fitted for
wardrobe
when i gave you that percentage this is
what i think based on
no specific knowledge that i will reveal
all right brian
in the meantime we'll just have to soak
in your awesome podcast and oral history
of the office podcast available now
exclusively
on spotify uh so you got a new episode
coming out this very tuesday correct
that's every tuesday yeah and uh yeah
and you're guessing
we start we we start looking toward the
end well last week
we we covered the period of time when
steve carell left
and and and now the show is is rapidly
coming to an end so
we'll um we'll hear from a lot of
different people about
um kind of the decision that was made
for
why we decided that it was time
for the show to be over okay brian
thanks for the call let's chat more
and go hit him straight when you can get
out there obviously let's do it
absolutely
thanks for calling rich i appreciate it
right back at you of course the very
popular brian baumgartner is
um podcast an oral history of the office
podcast available
on spotify at bb bombgartner on
twitter he's also on instagram as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here